hi this is preshtalker in this video
we're going to describe the math of what
a standard drink is
in America they often say that one beer
is equal to one glass of wine which is
also equal to one shot of hard alcohol
but where did they come up with this
equivalency between different types of
alcohol
the reason is the definition of a
standard drink is 0.6 fluid ounces of
alcohol and each of these drinks
actually contains that amount of alcohol
we can verify this by looking at the
alcohol percentage of each of the drinks
and we'll also write down the standard
serving size of each of these drinks
when we multiply the alcohol percentage
by the drink size we find that each of
these drinks contains the standard 0.6
fluid ounces of alcohol
and this is great for Theory but what
happens in practice let's say you go to
a bar and order a tall craft beer
now very likely This Tall craft beer may
have seven percent alcohol
and a tall beer is often served in a 23
ounce
glass
so what you end up with is about 2.7
standard drinks
similarly if you get a cocktail and
someone serves you a strong cocktail
you may end up with something which has
a little bit higher alcohol percentage
and it might have a little more alcohol
than the standard serving
and so you'll end up with more than just
one standard drink
you can even run into trouble with wine
many Wines in fact are not 12 percent
but they are 15 and someone might serve
you a little more than a standard
serving size
so even with wine you can end up with
nearly double the amount of alcohol
so if you want to keep track of this
number of drinks you're having in a
night you can follow this formula the
number of standard drinks will be equal
to the volume times the alcohol
percentage divided by 0.6 the numerator
tells you how much alcohol is in your
drink and the denominator standardizes
this to one drink equivalent
you can often find the alcohol
percentage just by looking at the label
and looking for the ABV which is the
alcohol by volume there are many
websites and even smartphone apps
that'll do this calculation for you
but if you find this is all too much
trouble you can save yourself the
calculation the calories and the cash by
choosing not to drink for the night
I hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and Game Theory you can support me
on patreon to get exclusive Rewards
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
on Twitter at preshtalwicker and you can
get my books listed on my website